Good morning.
You know, everybody always ask me why I use candles all the time,
but, like,
does this not just make life a little cozier?
Let me show you how I make my morning coffee.
Things first, you're gonna start with an egg yolk.
We're actually starting with a different egg,
cause that other one was fertilized and had an embryo in it,
and I don't want that in my coffee.
Turn on the light so y'all can see what I'm doing.
But I'm just taking sugar.
You can use any sweetener you want. Just doing about
a tablespoon and a half cocoa powder.
Tablespoon.
And take real salt. Redmond's real salt.
Because I don't want table salt,
I want real salt.
Just a pinch.
Little mini blender and half. Half.
This is a lot better if you use heavy cream. But look at that.